[Music]
this notion that these kids are lazy
when i went on to become the face of
work ethic
shouldn't that tell you something every
teacher lazy lazy lazy
how about disinterested in your [ __ ]
mrs thompson
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
hey everybody uh really excited for
another interview uh
starting to try to gear these back up
after a year where i probably did two or
three uh today's
is very important to me i did this uh i
did the podcast
uh on on her incredible platform and i'm
a
uh excited advisor and board member of
this incredible
ambitious massive project that abby is
going on that i think as soon as i give
her the floor for next five minutes
you'll see why
in my crazy busy world i said sure um
and
uh and i'm really excited and so uh i
mean why don't you tell everybody here
in the vaynernation who you are
and what you're doing and then we'll
poke and prod
hello and yes i am i'm so thankful for
your time gary because this is an
important issue
to everyone there's not anyone out there
who's not a product of education
so i am an educator but i'm also a
futurist and i believe in people and
their purpose
and making good in the world and what we
know about the education system today
we have real statistics 14 success rate
so of the people that enter higher
education 14
come out served and serve for me just
means they graduate
lowest bill uh bar possible that they
have a degree that has more market value
than its costs
didn't cost more than its actual value
and three they're using it
that's 14 that actually follow those
criteria coming out of higher ed
and everyone complains you know the
trillion dollar
college jet crisis there's a lot going
on there's a lot of reason there's a lot
of hurt
but the future is here and i am here and
i am working towards and created this
company called the mix where
we are believe that education is
personal and this
idea that we can put all students into
this one box of like college or not
college and these are the roads you have
is a ridiculous expectation and gary you
talk a lot about
how asking 17 year olds to know what
they want to do with the rest of their
lives
is the most absurd concept in the world
could not agree with you more and more
educators need to come out and say it
because our system puts them into a path
that they're not even ready to make
so mix is the future and it's personal
where every single individual can say
that again because i want people to know
the url and the spelling and all that
yeah mix is here to solve this problem
it is the mix www.themix.com with a why
because it's about you
it's about your journey your goals your
interests
and finding the education that maps that
that one doesn't put you in debt
okay education and ideas should be free
look at professor v
over here right he's spouting he's
telling you and that's not giving
something away
that makes you gary stronger and
educators need to look the same as well
when you look in the mirror and say
we can do better and the environments
and the college campuses
can be more you know current college
campus you're paying tens of thousands
of dollars
what are you really getting the size
that eight percent of the time that's in
classroom
the 92 percent nothing happens
so that's what the mix is about we
believe that 92
really matters and how you show up in
the world and that it should be
life versus school like should i go do
life or should i do school
no these two need to communicate it's
both you can have
both your education can inform your life
and your life can inform your education
and that's what makes and these we're
enrolling students
every week and we're about to change the
world in a huge way
you know the idea that you two student
can go to
harvard or go get a certification from
google and go straight to work
and not have to go to community college
and go into debt it's
life-changing and it's all really new so
the biggest concern right now going out
there is
educating the market so many people are
still
binders on college or business college
or bus parents especially right
college or bus and they don't know that
the world has changed significantly in
the last year
in regards do you think they don't know
or do you think
college in modern times has crossed the
chasm to almost be religion
and that that's the tough part that like
you run in circles you you have an
illustrious serious education career
right you know avenue i mean you've got
a real career
um do you think it's just an ideology
yeah i do i think rightfully so you want
children to have the experience you
experience right just like you want your
children to grow up in the church
if you grew up in the church same thing
the problem
is the game has changed they can't
equate it
yes i don't understand the same
experience but the outcome is no longer
the same
this experience is not the same either
not it's not it's just not
it's three times the price i mean wages
have remained stagnant tuition continues
to go like this
so the millennial generation is the most
disenfranchised most hindered and hurt
generation
ever by higher education truly criminal
activity going
on with millennials and the debt they
are facing for the rest of their lives
so i understand a parent wanting the
safe normal
pathway what they had they want their
children to experience it
but we know that doesn't work and it's
not serving them and that there are
other options
when do you have your moment i mean you
know actually why don't you tell
everybody about your career in education
real fast because we don't have a lot of
time today i'm sorry i'm rushing yo
i'm recording this while the friends is
still trying to get launched talk about
trying to educate
um give us one minute on your education
career because i think it's going to
help a lot of parents that are listening
right now like
you know this is real [ __ ] now like
you're a real g from that world and i
and i have a series of questions about
that so
give them that real quick so my
background is i'm an
educator by research i'm a real data
scientist
and i we know a lot more about how the
brain learns and that's the approach i
bring to education
we know for a fact that the brain does
not learn from passively taking
information
without any understanding of why it's
important that is about 99
of the current education process that is
the pedagogy that is the approach
you sit i talk you listen you
regurgitate
we know that you will not remember any
of that and every person listening think
back to your college experience or high
school do you remember those classes for
any content i mean don't even talk to me
you know i basically tuned out in fourth
grade
please but you do remember some things
you remember that second grade
ab i'm sorry to interrupt but what about
like
when did you when were you in your field
at places like avenues and other places
and said uh-oh you know everybody has
that moment i mean
everybody has that moment if they
transition to the you know you're
talking about institutions that you used
to
work and help people strive to get into
yeah
and i'm and i'm trying to change you're
trying to gather yeah no that's
and by the way that's exactly right
because like i change i'll give you one
let me let me be vulnerable
i was very against candor and created a
little lollipop wonderland in all my
companies
and now have changed my tune and writing
a new book where kind candor is like a
big part of the book
so like i actually think changing your
mind is the ultimate strength i also
think things
change i also think that college today
as an roi is different than it was 10
years ago 20 years ago 30 years ago 40
years ago
but i'm actually just genuinely curious
if there was like maybe if there was a
kid you know like i think about myself
right
i was so scolded as you're a loser
by by politically incorrect early late
80s early 90s teachers
and and i want and mrs kennedy senora
kennedy big shout out to senora kennedy
if anybody knows her
from north hunter in high school in the
90s
she i really got it she's like uh-uh
this guy's not this guy's actually gonna
be the winner of the whole thing
and i always wonder if like my
then going on to pull that off how that
affected how she taught
others or was i the byproduct of her
seeing that in prior students
than me mm-hmm there's two moments
two very personal moments one was my own
college experience
but where i was i went to duke
university yeah i was paying the exact
same price
as all my roommates they all went into
finance and law
and i went into a job that paid thirty
six
thousand dollars but yet i paid the same
price
and how is that fair and the when i'll
never forget is that graduation
from duke they had all the people that
are graduating with a certificate and
teaching stand
in the audience of thousands of people
there were three of us standing
and i was like holy did i like am i bad
my bad like was this the wrong move is
this not smart use
this education so the fact that
education isn't aligned with the outcome
to me
made no sense and criminal because who's
going to become a teacher
hence the teacher shortage that's the
first one the second time where i
realized
that education was falling short of
making life-ready individuals
was when um as an adult who's been
privileged enough to have incredible
access to education and then create one
of the best schools in the nation
so i'm an expert in my field on
education
found myself completely unready for the
world my husband got diagnosed with
stage four lung cancer out of the blue
and i sat up in the middle of night and
i realized i have no skills
in regards to personal finance
in regards to what is a mortgage like i
literally
do is it a piece of paper do i find it
somewhere is it a drawer
i had no skills to take care of my two
children
and i realized what if it's not
why are these things just like
expectations are never taught and how
when we always blame it's always blame
they're lazy right
right they're lazy they're like by the
way by the way literally this is insane
the first part of my entire life you're
too lazy
the last 10 years of my life you're
working too hard
and the whole time i'm in my head i'm
like none of you [ __ ] know who i
am right they don't always sleep an hour
eight hours a day they don't know that
the 16 hours a day that i go hard
i'm calm even in the storm of this
[ __ ] failed
launch honestly i don't give a [ __ ]
as long as everyone in my family is
healthy like this is just business
my my you're gonna burn out garyvee i'm
like no you're gonna burn out because
you're anxious
i'm not gonna burn out i'm doing my
hobby even when it's shitty like i'm in
right now
i'm gonna step out of it for a second
and support a friend and put it on my
podcast because she's got a big mission
i'm going to play basketball with my
little guy like i'm just like i don't
give a [ __ ] like
of course i give a [ __ ] i have pride but
like
this notion that these kids are lazy
when i went on to become the face of
work ethic shouldn't that tell you
something
every teacher lazy lazy lazy how about
disinterested
in your [ __ ] mrs thompson that's it
and that's what the mix is
what the genius piece of it is you
should be able to curate your classes to
actually have meaning for you
this whole idea go figure and you need
three credits of
you know science and rocks and you're
just sitting there and that's
thousands of dollars by the way that
you're throwing at a class that you know
you don't need
but yet someone deems you need it for
this credit
you know like i love when you say gary
you gotta i love what i do
like when i'm not loving what i do i do
something else well that's what this
generation gen z has kind of been
brought up to do
they they're able to because their
digital natives take in and get what
they want in a moment's notice
education should be the same there's no
reason it shouldn't be
and that's why it mixed you curate your
classes
if you're not interested in taking
english 101 and you know exactly that
you want to be a social media manager
go do that go try it on for a little bit
because the one thing that we need to
tell this youth which i would love to
get this message out there
the the higher education system was made
for the industrial revolution for that
economy
so it's no longer valid we've known that
for a long time but what we haven't been
saying is we've been saying students
take out two hundred thousand dollars in
loans because that'll set you up for
life
you're good you're totally good no no no
these kids are going to have 11 lives
screw the seven they're gonna have 11.
and many of these lives we don't know
about don't exist because those jobs
have not been created
like an influence or content creation
all these new jobs are there's a lot
more coming up
so for us to pretend that higher
education and colleges
can give you a one-stop shop in your
education
that's just not clear that's that's not
the truth these students will need
education throughout their life so go
try something on go live a little
get the certification get out there in
the world break before i
lose you break down the mix so the
website
the costs the actual business you're
trying to build
yeah bring it down so the mix is the
future of higher education where we are
a holistic
you choose the what okay so you curate
your classes with a team
those classes can be as cheap as three
to you know 425 dollars from the top
learning institutions
and this is exciting stuff about online
net not just the united states but the
world
let's look at oxford let's look at
sydney who's the best in the field
go get taught by them don't go to the
local community college get taught by
the
best in the field for cheaper that's the
first piece then you choose where
where are you going to activate so the
number one most transformed experience
in higher education is going abroad we
need to make that more accessible
is only for the privilege so the mix for
just seventy six hundred dollars
you get which is average room and board
at a university for a semester but what
do you get for that at a university you
get a dorm room some cinder blocks
bathrooms
right like what do you get by the way by
the way i'm sorry to interrupt you
because
go ahead finish finish your thought go
ahead but at mix what you do now is you
bring that online education that you
curated that's for
you and then you activate it in costa
rica medellin get out in the world get
worldly perspectives sometimes i i like
to say you have to be lost before you're
found
to find your purpose sometimes you need
to stretch yourself the
easiest way to do that statistically
speaking from educational outcomes is
going abroad
so the mix is an ecosystem of 60 houses
around the world
were you on that site are you at 60
already
no we will be three right now yes i got
i like lost my mind i'm like
i've been in i've been in this v friends
tornado i didn't realize that much
happened
yes we we're at three right now we're at
three right now
costa rica columbia and here in the us
in miami
and when you're there you do real world
experience
so a graduate from mix and this is by
the way informed like people
hiring managers like you you don't
really care if they go to school anymore
it does
not matter we've elon musk all the
biggest names saying
i don't care what i want to k oh i care
about is how they show up
are they team players and show me the
skills
so a mixed graduate person with real
work experience because they're doing
work in the field
applying their online learning and
that's what people learn not from
passive
they'll do the passive but then they'll
apply it with us they get one-to-one
life coaching
because why in education do we ever stop
and say what's your purpose in life
never doesn't happen one-to-one life
coaching and we've created like
most vibing community ever like what
could college campus be if you're in the
middle of costa rica with 150 friends
about you know wanting to open your
horizons and see the world
so we're creating a network of like
incredible houses and global students
who are traveling the world to make the
most and demand more of their education
break down the people that are listening
right now what they should be thinking
about as
student parent or probably the part that
i'm most excited about which is
scholarship provider if they own a
business things that nature
bring down your three constituents yeah
so
parents what should a student what
should a student be thinking is it as
simple as
right this normal way doesn't work for
me this is a better cost alternative
and it's gonna be cooler more
interesting and i'm gonna learn more and
and
having a degree now from these other
places isn't as automatic as it used to
be so thus
this is what might happen yeah what
about what did you just hear that one
because i think
yeah what about parent because that's
the [ __ ] parent is the one
yeah and rightfully so okay so a parent
they're scared
because i don't know if it's rightfully
so
it might be circumstantially so right
rightfully so is i want what's best for
my kid so let me get and i've had this
debate
very aggressively with dear friends and
business i'm like
ones that have made their kids go to
college and not paid for it
it's one thing if you're paying for it
and the kid wants to take the bag
and hang out and hook up and have fun
and learn you know like fine
do you know how many parents make their
kids and when when i say make
i love my a really good friend it was
like i didn't make them like yes you did
i know you
you would say college is important when
you're propaganding
into your kid's head you know and you're
not paying for it
[ __ ] you yeah
it's a tough it's a religion right i
mean you said it best it's
really hard for a parent to take risks
on their child but when parents say well
you know
anything off the given track is a risk i
say well let's talk we know your track
let's talk about the risk on that it's
14 success succeed
and when i say succeed i go like this
because 79 percent of the mental health
um don't you know are having abuse not
healthy lifestyles whatever success
means to fulfillment all those things
so the first thing i would say to
parents and students is you need to know
that we're going to be facing a real
reckoning in higher ed it's already
happening
so this whole idea of hybrid and if that
would be good for me no no
every university will be hyper in the
future mark my words they will have to
out of necessity to bring down costs
is the only way for their survival
another thing that every parent should
know
is that the long-term roi on education
has this much to do with the classroom
and everything to do with the experience
so
think hard about where they're going and
what they're doing with that
92 because we you understand the eight
percent really well you understand class
that's all you're sold
when you go to university and they talk
about they don't really talk about what
happens
after class can we create a more
sustainable and interesting environment
for example why are college campuses the
most segregated communities in the
united states
when they are the most diverse by
numbers all these things
you should be thinking about parents and
students when deciding that you're going
to incubate your child
for four years and yes there is party
the party's important i just want to be
honest
party's going gonna be vibing at mix
because it's that's part of this
developmental age and you gotta honor it
learning you know and and throwing up
but that but the party is based on
like a hundred other variables like like
they're like
it's the city you're in like right like
if you're in miami
you don't need to be in college there's
a party every night that's way better
than
ohio state all respect to ohio
yeah not even that i mean colleges to
survive they
quad you in it's literally called a quad
they are reliant on your spending power
on campus they don't want you to leave
there's very big incentives
to keep everyone on campus that's not
how and then we
then we graduate from the real world and
they don't have a food plan and they
don't know what to do
you're preaching i mean listen i'm i'm
so like
holding back your a because i'm tired of
slept six hours in like six weeks it
feels like with this [ __ ] be
friends b i want to i want to get better
at letting my guests speak
see i don't think there's a single
person listed in this podcast that
doesn't know where i stand which is by
the way why am i on the board of pencils
of promise
it's building schools i am a huge
advocate for education the biggest it's
what i do
i i just gonna say you aren't educators
it's what i do
i just think that people have to be by
the way i think there's a lot of people
that should go to college
absolutely i think there's a lot of
people that win in that format
um think about wait but the kids people
from mix are going to college
they're just doing online and traveling
the world while doing it
they're making more of the experience
they're not just going to
get a degree and get that paper and be
one of thousands with the paper
people do people think you're crazy when
i hear that like i'm putting i was just
listening to you talk
do your fellow you know educators of the
past think you're crazy
or are they cheering you on on the side
being like do it so i can come and join
what's been the
reception the reception has been really
positive because there's not an educator
out there that doesn't know
that how the brain learns to pretend
that we think that the current system
actually functions the way people learn
and process information
there's not one educator out there the
problem is everyone keeps saying what's
it going to be and how are we going to
change it
and they keep relying on the institution
to change
they can't they're so big in mammoth and
there's
always side building and the english
teachers and those two people don't
communicate because there are different
buildings in different silos
there's no such thing as an english job
everything is cross-dimensional
you're going to need all the skills of
all those locations and we need to stop
thinking in silos
let people get the content specialized
in the content
at their price and that fits their goals
but we can make the campus experience
and get american children out there in
the real world
getting experience so that when they do
step out of college
they're prepared i mean 96 of hiring
managers say
they can't find quality coming out of
college they cannot find
workers and then they have to train them
well what if
we could do both at once what if it's
not school versus life experience but
them at the same time
so they communicate so another big issue
is these kids
ridiculously so are asked to pick a
major they have no idea what a public
policy major is
and then by the time they're finally
figured out and they're two years in
they have all this sunken costs and
money and they can't get out
and they can't switch so why not have a
more exploratory where you find out
right away because you're doing the job
you're not just learning about public
policy you're applying it so that
within one semester you know you know
what i hate this
that is a very powerful thing to know to
make some real decisions
informed decisions about your education
and that's what the future is going to
be and it's cheaper
so i one of the things we get is how is
it so cheap
i get that question asked all the time
like i'm expecting to pay
80 000 like how are you telling me 7
600 because what we do is we
leveraged the best of online education
use the internet as a tool
to give content because guess what it
gives it better you hear it from the
best
and you do it at your own time and
allowing some learners to slow down or
for some learners
fast forward right and that allows
us to then focus on community what it
means to be
at this age what our purpose development
life skills development you know at the
mix we teach everything from cyber
security
talk nowhere in higher education but
these kids need to know it because our
identities are 100
at risk in the future we teach them
basic things from contract law
this was based off the fact that college
graduates can't sign their own lease
agreements from their first apartment
never taught anyone
what's the website one more time as we
wrap up here www.themixwithawmyx.com
because you
curate your future no one else there are
no freshmen
at nix there is doug's and caroline's
and sally's
and that much because every person gets
to create their pathway
and find something that fits their
pocketbook more important
everybody please check it out hit up
abby i think there's a lot of people in
this community because i get
millions through the years conversations
around this this is not just about the
students in here
or to consider this this is about people
that are passionate about
education changing in america and abroad
in the world
and so if uh check out the website and
hit them up if there's anything you want
to
jam with them on anything that's right
one thing gary
please we have just doubled down on our
financial aid
endowment fund because we are speaking
to the class of 2021
and they're hurting and we are there for
you guys this has been a tough ride
everyone talked about 2020
class of 2021 we hear you we're there
for you
we have aid come come don't let that
stop you
okay education is important youtube
what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon